avec cette vidéo retransmise en direct
sur écran géant le président volodymyr
zelensky s'adresse aux foules massées
aux quatre coins de l'europe celui
devenu la figure de la résistance
ukrainienne est acclamé lors de son
apparition comme ici à francfort
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
7 premières minutes je voudrais l'a
consacré à une minute de silence pour
ceux qui sont tombés au combat
à travers l'europe ils sont des milliers
est venu par solidarité
je pense que si le monde entier vous que
nous nous préoccupons de la situation
ils feront quelque chose pour les gens
qui souffrent nous devons faire quelque
chose et le faire très vite
de francfort à prague de la slovaquie à
la géorgie partout la même volonté de
voir la guerre prendre fin et un même
élan de compassion envers les ukrainiens
les ukrainiens mérite notre soutien le
plus total car le combat qu'il mène
c'est aussi notre combat
pour ces manifestants l'enjeu va au-delà
des frontières de l'ukraine
nous défendons notre liberté parce que
nous pensons que c'est la chose la plus
importante pour laquelle il vaut la
peine de se battre
c'est terrible ce qui arrive à des
personnes innocentes là-bas aux enfants
qui perdent leurs parents et leurs
proches
dans son message claudemir saelens qui
alerte si l'ukraine tombe c'est toute
l'europe qui tombera une possibilité
d'une défaite que n'envisage cependant
pas le président qui s'est montré nos
petits
quand nous gagnerons parce que je crois
que nous gagnerons ce sera une grande
victoire de la démocratie une grande
victoire de la liberté
sur le continent de nouvelles
manifestations de soutien sont prévues
dans les prochains jours
[Musique]
à